[Music]
ruining the integrity of the floor for a
reveal
there are children standing nearby what
if this causes the floor to cave in
aunt may phineas and ferb are making a
crossover
snitches it was really nice of these
asteroids to make a perfect path for
surfing
also if the surfboard is jet powered
then really if anything they're just
surfing space and not the asteroids
right
not nearly as impressive now that i've
pointed that out huh
[Music]
isabella survives this also she is
entirely too happy to be flung into a
black hole
as walter hill once told me you never
want to go full supernova
it leads to months on end of reshoots
and changing your name to thomas lee
how do these children afford the
equipment needed for these episodes a
roller coaster build out of whatever
they find
sure but spacesuits rockets and space
stations
who funds this so i created the power
drainator to drain all his powers into
this canister
see the trouble with this show is that
we are trained to know that whatever
dooful boof explains doesn't really
matter because it'll be foiled by the
end i mean
great he gets to be excited about
whatever he's done but do we care
anymore i'll finally be able to use
these
cartoon character pulls comically large
object from impossible places cliche
take some more love modoc that's it for
you
can i web not only is it convenient as
hell that the energy from phineas and
ferb space station was aimed directly at
where the four superheroes were standing
but it's also pretty convenient that
this was the moment they were all
huddled together
especially considering most people
really want space after a save the
planet from evildoer's workout
and i had to leave mjolnir in the street
but why did you have to leave it you
were able to pick it up and throw it
just
not very far at least you guys aren't
locked inside this metal procedure
but why is he locked in the middle suit
you're telling me tony stark didn't
include a get out of suit free button
when he built the damn thing
because i do not believe you man do i
regret having that second cup of coffee
this morning but why is he locked in a
metal suit you're telling me tony stark
didn't think of having to relieve
himself and didn't include a mini toot
tank when he built the damn thing
because i do not believe you no no
you're missing the big one micromanaging
a mysterious ray has drained the power
from four of our beloved superheroes we
now return you to horse in a bookcase
already in progress
even in a cartoon convenient news
position is still convenient
and a sin also not giving us an episode
of horse in a bookcase omg
i drained all the powers from my group
of superheroes
all the way in new york blogs you know
you really should use sunblock touching
someone's skull without explicit consent
juice in a box we have nothing like this
in asgard but it's available on
earth which you've been to several times
oh boy if iron man can't even walk or
stand up why do they keep bringing him
along
hey wait a minute were you wearing that
eye patch when we started how can fury
see the major if they are on two
separate screens and the majors is not
at an angle where
he could be seen maybe he is a
misunderstood genius
or maybe he is a perfectly understood
idiot red skull would be villainous at
tv sins
look at these [ __ ] not letting the
floating head go first knowing that this
would be his moment to shine by lighting
the flowers on fire
stealing bags from vacuum cleaners
stealing
let's go get some ice cream and spoil
our dinner well you should have just
stolen the ice cream off the kids cone
earlier instead of flicking it onto the
floor
you've swapped all their powers it
shouldn't be an issue considering we can
see the console is perfectly fine now
even though it was broken a moment ago
plug that thing in and let's wrap this
up
says the person who just earlier this
morning was in space and also descending
to earth on a floating grass screw while
not freaking out despite the height
phineas and ferb survive this now i'm
iron man
but also suddenly very strong again
considering you've dangled a washer off
your chest and can lug around microwaves
as shoes without issue the time for
heroes is over
what comic book fans hear every time
martin score says he says something
somehow makes it into the script
sadly there is no time our mission lies
elsewhere
yep super on brand for a hero to abandon
a small child with deadly powers
entering a tower filled with villains
with two loud rockets strapped to your
body
why does goofy plurts have a human-sized
cage if he's always trapping perry
that's kind of on you candace you're the
big sister why don't you just beat
phineas up until he says uncle and steal
some money from him that you don't even
need but he'd saved up enough for almost
like a sega genesis or something and
i hate you rebecca for example when you
grab somebody's shirt to lift them up
look if buford knew enough about the
hulk to talk belgique down then he
definitely knows what will
rile him back up again i get the show
has to get belgian hulking out again but
it could have come up with a more
interesting way than this giving buford
a moment of brilliance and then taking
it away from him seems a little
mean-spirited especially for this show
do not yell it by jeet like that
don't worry beaufort lands on a soft
pillow because this show cares about him
but [ __ ] all the people in this subway
car am i right
unless iron man spider-man soar and hulk
show up to face us we will unleash a
device a thousand times worse than the
one that hits him which makes me wonder
why aren't there more superheroes in
danville now before we have were the
only ones who got their powers taken
away why wasn't the first move calling
in some backup
uh guys you better come see this you'd
better come take a look at this cliche
mota can you feel it in your brain when
i go like this
fondling someone's ball brain so you're
a superhero huh
don't you have some sort of power to get
us out of this why is perry just pulling
out the wire cutters now he's been in
this cage for all the sometimes
now that i'm looking at the construction
of phineas and ferb suit how does ferb
even breathe in this thing
and if ferb is this far up in the suit
how was he not killed earlier when
whiplash sliced the suit in half that
action should have also sliced ferb in
half and i demand to see some kid's guts
wait look the collection
telling someone sister how hot their
brother is no isabella i failed twice
already so third time's a charm
this works sort of too short too short
too long forgetting that too long also
means long enough
yo heroes got a little something for you
is it a massive container of death
defying plot convenience
because that's the only possible reason
this space station made it through
earth's atmosphere intact and these two
idiots managed to stay alive and win the
day
i think perhaps our window of
opportunity has crossed but you fought
them when they had powers before so
what would stop you now why don't you
kids take five
enjoy the show i'll give all the sins
back if the next scene is of iron man
racing to the bathroom to finally
relieve himself after being trapped in
this suit all day holding in the real
bomb
yeah hot dogs for everyone baby
repetitive stan lee's celebrity
appearance is repetitive
so we're just leaving belgium with hulk
powers then everybody good with this
okay oh yes there they are but where's
the person working the shop
you can't just leave all that stuff out
in the open i don't even understand how
those comic books are still there
twice the pride double the full the
tri-state area
the chinese state area tri-state area
tri-state area the entire tri-state area
to take over the tri-state area the
surrounding tri-state
area entire tri-state area the entire
tri-state destroy the tri-state area
i can't breathe in this thing wanna hang
out with us on a live stream we don't
care if you're on the toilet in your
mom's basement or in the broom closet
just put on some deodorant and join us
during sin week
20 21 march 22 through 26th we'll
release
three extra sense videos and go live
four times to hang out with you all you
have to do is become a sin club member
at patreon.com
cinemasins do it now that way you're the
first to learn about our evil plans
and if you join today you have time to
watch over 70 exclusive videos and
podcasts
see you the week of the 22nd well i'll
tell you stu i did battle some humongous
waves
but you know just like i told the guy on
abc
danger is my business why aren't you in
space
it's cold and empty and it wants to kill
you
for the record she may look like a 34c
but she's getting all kinds of help from
our friends at victoria's secret
but can we get something to eat now
otherwise whoever
it's starting to look really really good
ferb
are you expecting someone i am your
singing telegram
meanwhile at the hall of justice